I just found this on the desk.
Oh my God.
Ah!
You're still so into it.
We were talking during the break,
about that, an old Western town,
you know that they're making?
The real estate fantasy
that's like inspired by Yellowstone.
Uh huh. I really wanna move in.
I could open a little bonnet shop
and a little singles bar called,
(audience laughs)
can you imagine a singles bar called 'The Hoe Down'?
Just come on out.
(audience laughs)
Right?
Double entendre, I love it.
(Ross laughs)
All right.
What else you got, Rossy?
Well, we do have a new design trend.
You know, I just got a new house.
Drew's gonna help me,
'cause like every wall is white.
I'm so scared of anything, and I'm not alone,
but there are a lot of people using colors.
And Apartment Therapy reports,
wallpaper is flying off the shelves,
specifically flowered wallpaper.
(audience claps)
People, yeah!
They're putting the petal to the metal,
and we're talking in the first half of January alone,
sales of wallpaper went up, wow!
412% you guys.
So what is behind this, Drew?
I've always been scared to do it,
'cause I think I'm gonna mess it up.
I wouldn't even know who to call to put wallpaper up,
but people are figuring it out.
Well, you're calling the right person.
Every wallpaper you just saw,
we made and designed with Flower Home.
So all of those-
That's all yours?
(audience claps)
Were ours.
Would you ever do a floral wallpaper?
100%. Like I love the idea of a powder room
with a bold wallpaper, right?
When you walk into a small bathroom,
and it's like a lot, I always go, 'Oh'.
Like that makes me so happy.
Can I do a Design by Drew
(Ross gasps)
in your new house, powder room edition?
Any room you want!
(audience claps)
Done, done, done, done, done, done, done, done.
Oh my God!
All right!
I'm so excited!
Ooh, project for Rossy.
(Ross laughs)
Next up, a brave woman named Meelayna
went viral on TikTok and asked,
'What's your crappiest dating story'?
Ooh, that's brave.
Mine took place last summer.
Ooh.
(Ross laughs)
I've talked about it a million times,
it's true.
Was the worst.
In the first 10 minutes I was like,
'Get me out of here'.
Really?
Tell me why again,
which one was this one?
He told me he had the affair that blew up his marriage
and his daughter found out,
and I'm just like.
Oh wow.
What's wrong with you?
You were messy.
Messy.
Do you remember my worst date ever?
I was on a date with a guy.
It was going well, we had fun.
And then his boyfriend showed up,
(Drew and audience laugh)
because it apparently it wasn't a date,
it was just hanging with a friend.
How do you think you misunderstood the situation
or did he mislead you?
I just assumed it was my fault,
somewhere along the way, I just assumed.
Yeah. I mean, I guess I should have been clear.
It's like when you asked me to dinner and drinks, alone,
I should have asked if it was a date.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
We have pretty bad stories Drew,
but when I read this story,
I think this woman might have topped us.
Ugh, this one is gnarly, get ready for this.
The Sun reports,
she wasn't quite ready for the answer of like
'What is your worst dating story'?
Because a woman walked into her date's house
to find at his bedside that he was building a tower
out of every piece of chewing gum he'd ever chew.
(Ross and audience laugh)
Oh my God.
(Drew makes weird noise)
Is that a picture of it?
Wait, is that a picture of it?
Yeah, I know,
and I can't even look at it.
Oh my God.
I can't even look at it,
makes me wanna puke.
Oh my God.
You know what that pile needs,
is a bucket right next to him.
(audience laughs)
So I can just,
(Ross makes vomiting noises)
every time I look at the pile.
Now Ross, is this a story you can chew on,
or what?
(Ross screeches as audience laughs)
(audience and Ross clap)
I try.
Sammy told us a story,
that I don't think I can even share it,
it's so foul.
Sammy, our producer?
Uh huh.
She said she knew someone who collected boogers.
(all laugh)
She didn't.
She knew someone who knew someone.
(Ross laughs)
I'm just saying.
Maybe our lives aren't so bad, Rossy.
(Drew and Ross laugh)
Maybe we're getting out pretty clean.
Things are looking up.
(upbeat music)